vous le savez certainement depuis
quelques mois un chatbot appelé chat GPT
a été rendu accessible au grand public
et sa spectacularité a conduit tous les
grands médias à en parler certains
parlant même de révolution ou de
technologie de rupture et bien souvent
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme et oui je
porte des gants parce que je filme ça
chez moi et comme il y a pas le choix
j'ai fait vachement froid chez moi ceci
étant de nombreuses voix critiques se
sont soulevées comme vous pouvez vous en
rendre compte en lisant par exemple la
page wikipédia de chaque GPT et si vous
faites cet exercice vous verrez que
parmi les critiques il y a un certain
les Nguyen ou un angle pourtant le grand
danger de chaque GPT à Meyzieu n'est pas
listé dans cette page wikipédia et il
n'est quasiment jamais cité dans les
médias à part ceux qui m'ont invité à
parler de ce danger et pour vraiment
clarifier ce danger je vais m'appuyer
sur un chiffre
6000 milliards de dollars
6000 milliards de dollars c'est d'après
le Sénat français une estimation
raisonnable du revenu annuel du
cybercrime
milliards de dollars c'est le double du
PIB de la France et ses quatre fois plus
que Google Amazon Facebook Apple et
Microsoft combiné or on peut estimer que
chaque GPT a coûté quelques dizaines de
millions peut-être quelques centaines de
millions pour être conçu notamment à
cause de la facture d'électricité mais
aussi à cause des salaires des
ingénieurs et de la collecte éthiquement
douteuses des données pour éduquer
chaque GPT comme on en a parlé chez
Monsieur fille mais surtout vu ce
copenhay a partagé pété ne semble pas
s'appuyer sur des techniques novatrices
en fait il existe toute une jungle
d'algorithmes de langage similaire dont
certains comme lambda et palme de Google
dont les progrès sont sûrement
comparables et d'autres encore qui sont
open source comme Dumble de hogging face
mais surtout la sur médiatisation des
prouesses de chaque GPT a déjà amplifié
les investissements déjà massifs dans le
développement de ces technologies voire
à convaincre certaines entreprises de
réduire leur seuil de sécurité avant de
déployer ces technologies ce qui va
certainement conduire à des algorithmes
bien plus spectaculaires encore que
chaque GPT dans les années voire dans
les mois qui viennent or les moyens
actuels légaux financiers et humains
pour auditer et réguler ces technologies
sont extrêmement déficients et les
lobbies industriels s'appuient souvent
sur le succès de chaque GPT et la course
à la performance pour dénigrer les
appels à la régulation qui plus est ce
que chaque GPT a montré à toute
l'industrie du cybercrim c'est à quel
point ces algorithmes de langage
pouvaient booster leur business en
automatisant l’écriture de logiciel
malveillant les attaques par phishing
les arnaques en ligne la désinformation
le cyber-harcèlement et les appels à la
haine entre autres enfin et surtout
chaque GPT est un dangereux cool washing
des intelligences artificielles et aide
à distraire toute la société de ses
applications les plus dangereuses que ce
soit pour les claviers intelligents qui
lisent tout ce que vous tapez sur vos
téléphones la publicité qui exploite ses
données et d'autres pour optimiser les
appels à la surconsommation des
entreprises privées ou la recommandation
algorithmique de contenu qui bien plus
que Google Search ou chaque GPT est
devenu le portail principal à travers
lequel les humains accèdent web en quand
on me demande si chaque GPT il pourra
remplacer Google Search j'ai surtout
envie de répondre que l'algorithme de
Tik Tok a déjà largement remplacé Google
Search bref à bien y réfléchir le plus
grand danger avec chaque GPT ce n'est
pas chat GPT lui-même c'est tout ce qui
l'impliquent pour l'écosystème du
développement des intelligences
artificielles de Chuck Nora
pour bien comprendre à quel point ce
serait une erreur de penser chaque GPT
de manière isolée il est important de
prendre un peu de recul sur le
développement de telles algorithmes en
fait depuis 2017 il y a un article de
recherche de Google publié à norrips
c'est l'une des plus grandes conférences
en machine learning les algorithmes de
langage s'appuient sur une même
architecture appelée le transformer
depuis ses algorithmes n'ont cessé de
progresser un rythme spectaculaire si
bien que les performances de tchat GPT
ne montrent personnellement pas vraiment
surpris en effet chaque année on
entraînant un algorithme dix fois plus
gros que le précédent et en l’alimentant
de 10 fois plus de données les équipes
de recherche des groupes privées n'ont
cessé de montrer que les modèles ainsi
créés gagner drastiquement en
spectacularité bref personnellement je
n'ai pas tout à fait l'impression que
chaque GPT est une rupture et encore
moins qu'il s'agit du dernier mot à ce
sujet on est dans une phase de
croissance exponentielle dans la
complexification de ces algorithmes
rendu notamment possible par
l'optimisation des machines pour les
calculs spécifiques de l'architecture
dite du transformer mais aussi et
surtout par l'in investissement en
spectaculaire dont le développement de
tels produits en particulier le facteur
limitant aujourd'hui à la spectacularité
de ses algorithmes n'est plus une
innovation algorithmique révolutionnaire
même s'il faut encore souvent combiner
plein de petites astuces le facteur
limitant c'est surtout l'ingénierie des
machines à calculer la collecte de
données massives et surtout la facture
d'électricité pour faire les calculs
nestiment ainsi que les meilleurs
modèles de langage coûtent des millions
de dollars en électricité en tout cas le
modèle Bloom conçu par roging face pour
le projet ouvert big science rapporte à
avoir dépensé de à 5 millions de dollars
en électricité pour chaque j'ai répété
ils ont peut-être mis les bouchées
doubles voire les bouchers x 10 voir
peut-être plus encore ou quelqu'un on
pourrait parler de dizaines voire de
centaines de millions de dollars mais
probablement pas beaucoup plus vu que
open high n'avait reçu qu'un milliard de
dollars d'investissement de Microsoft
bref ce que je veux surtout dire c'est
que la conception d'algorithmes de
langage et surtout une histoire d'argent
aujourd'hui en tout cas si on néglige
les problèmes de sécurité qui eux
nécessitent beaucoup plus de
développement à la fois au niveau de la
recherche et de l'ingénierie par
ailleurs si jamais il s'agissait
davantage une affaire d'expertise
notamment parce qu'il y a encore pas mal
d'astuces techniques à trouver Google
semble en fait mieux placé copenhae
puisque ce sont beaucoup plus eux qui
sont derrière les principales avancées
dans le domaine à la fois avec
l'architecture des Transformers mais
aussi avec des nouvelles machines à
calculer dédiées comme les Tenser
possessing unit ou TPU ou encore avec
des innovations plus récentes comme les
switch Transformers ou pas Waze en fait
Google a développé des chatbots
spectaculaires avant chat GPT à savoir
lambda et palme mais ils ont préféré ne
pas les rendre accessibles au grand
public notamment pour éviter tout retour
de bâton en fait ce qui se passe et sans
doute que Google a surtout beaucoup plus
à perdre en termes d'image que Microsoft
et Open height et ça me semble surtout
être la principale raison pour laquelle
ils n'ont pas misé sur une euphorie en
la rendant public comme ce café openerai
mais Google et openia ne sont absolument
pas les seuls à développer de tels
algorithmes suite à l'euphorie autour de
ces modèles de langage il y a eu de
nouveaux investissements massifs dans
ces technologies et avec notamment
l'avènement de solutions open source
comme il faut s'attendre à ce que dans
les années à venir accéder à des modèles
de langage très puissant se fassent à un
coût beaucoup plus raisonnable
qu'aujourd'hui voir que ça devienne
facile pour des acteurs malveillants qui
pourront affiner ces modèles comme bon
leur semble dès lors qu'importe que
chaque GPT aide et mesure de sécurité ou
non en provoquant une euphorie ils ont
essentiellement garanti l'apparition
imminente de modèles de langage bon
marché extrêmement puissant et
facilement reprogrammable par le
cybercrim pour que celui-ci continue à
voler des milliers de milliards de
dollars qui permettent des hôpitaux des
voitures et des systèmes bancaires en
danger en particulier dans ce cadre les
algorithmes à la chaîne GPT pour être
particulièrement dévastateur notamment
parce que les cybercriminels s'appuient
souvent avant tout sur le langage pour
piéger leur victime
le cybercrim justement parlons-en pour
commencer quand on tombe par cybercrimes
en gros on parle d'utiliser des outils
du numérique pour commettre des
infractions des délits voire des crimes
et il y a malheureusement une énorme
diversité de telle pratique je vous en
propose une petite classification ici
qui est très loin d'être exhaustive et
je vous renvoie notamment vers Wikipédia
pour une liste plus complète pour
commencer il y a les arnaques
typiquement il y a le fameux coup du
prince nigérian qui demande une aide
financière qui sera récompensée
ultérieurement mais ça c'est un peu
l'arnaque de l'an 2000 aujourd'hui des
arnaques similaires mais beaucoup plus
sophistiqués ont été développés comme
par exemple les love scams qui consiste
à séduire des célibataires en ligne
souvent pendant des mois avant de
demander de l'aide financière natax
similaire appelée l'attaque au faux
supports téléphoniques consiste à faire
croire à sa victime que son ordinateur
est compromis et qu'il lui faut
urgemment appeler un numéro d'aide sauf
que c'est justement au moment de l'appel
que l'arnaque est vraiment lieu par
exemple parce que l'attaquant demande
alors à l'utilisateur de se connecter à
son compte en banque en ligne en
écrivant le mot de passe que l'attaquant
pourra ainsi noter et si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur ce genre d'attaque je
vous recommande vivement cet excellente
en quête de MyCode globalement récupérer
vos codes d'accès à des sites Web est
une énorme activité du cybercrim et
l'une des manières les plus efficaces
pour y parvenir et l'attaque par
hameçonnage aussi appelé attaque par
phishing celles-ci est consiste
typiquement à faire visiter une page qui
ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau à la
page d'enregistrement d'un site très
connu comme Gmail ou Facebook sauf que
le mot de passe que vous rentrez sur
cette page est envoyé non pas à Google
ou à Facebook mais est envoyé
directement aux machines de l'attaquant
et alors quand il s'agit d'un compte
personnel c'est déjà très dangereux
notamment parce que l'attaquant peut
ensuite se faire passer pour vous pour
demander de l'aide financière à vos
proches mais quand il s'agit de votre
compte professionnel ceci peut mettre
votre entreprise en danger surtout si
vous travaillez dans une entreprise de
petite taille en particulier l'une des
attaques qui se normalisent de plus en
plus sur les entreprises c'est
d'exploiter de tels accès au système
d'information de l'entreprise pour le
paralyser en chiffrant par exemple
toutes les données utiles au
fonctionnement de l'entreprise comme les
informations des clients nécessaires
pour leur envoyer des factures les
attaquants sont ensuite typiquement
demander une rançon pour rétablir le
système d'information on parle alors
d'attaque par ransomware et comme on
parle ici John Oliver des milliers
d'hôpitaux ont déjà été hackés ainsi et
ont parfois dû refuser des clients en
état critique parce que le système
d'information était paralysé de façon
terrifiante les attaques par ransomware
se démocratise si bien qu'à marcher de
ransomware Asus a émergé ou n'importe
qui peut payer pour lancer sa propre
attaque sans avoir à coder quoi que ce
soit sauf que dans un contexte de guerre
entre superpuissance un star de la
Russie qui a cherché à paralyser le
système électrique ukrainien à l'aide de
bombe les intérêts à paralyser des
industries critiques d'ennemis vont bien
au-delà du simple profit financier dès
lors il faut craindre une cybergure
catastrophique voire notamment ainsi les
outils nécessaires pour effectuer une
attaque à grande échelle de Vienne
abordable un très grand nombre de
groupes il faudrait de plus en du
screindre des attaques de cyber
terrorisme ceci étant une grosse partie
du super clean et beaucoup plus vicieux
et discret en particulier les fraudes de
publicité d'identité et d'attribution
consiste à typiquement concevoir voler
ou racheter un grand nombre de
fauconstes pour ensuite produire une
quantité massive de désinformation pour
faire gonfler la popularité les prix ou
les cours de certains produits pour
amplifier le taux de cliquer donc de
recommandations de certains contenus
vous pour signaler massivement certains
contenus critiques de gouvernement de
partis politiques ou d'entreprises
privées ces faux comptes aujourd'hui
souvent contrôlées par des fermes de
troll ou si appeler usine à clic sont
aussi utilisés pour produire des shits
Storm et harceler massivement certaines
cibles ce même harcèlement peut aussi
abuser de Deep fake pour nuire à l'image
de ses cibles voire alors bien-être
mental notamment en produisant des deep
fake pornographiques love scan faut
supporter téléphonique hameçonnage
hansomware siberger cyberies ferme un
clic vague de harcèlement voir tes
informations et appelle à la haine cette
liste de cybercrim est loin d'être
exhaustive mais elle est déjà
extrêmement terrifiante et surtout très
clairement des algorithmes de langage
comme chaque GPT vont énormément
faciliter la tâche de ceux qui veulent
profiter de ces attaques illégales et ça
va du coup rendre beaucoup plus
difficile la tâche des professionnels de
la cybersécurité normaliser le coûting
de chaque GPT sans parler avec
insistance des dangers civilisationnels
de la démocratisation des algorithmes de
langage et des besoins urgents de Moyaux
monumentaux pour protéger les sociétés
contre le cybercrime c'est rendre toute
la population plus vulnérable encore à
des disruptions majeures des systèmes
d'information critiques dont nos
sociétés dépendent tant qu'il s'agissent
des hôpitaux du réseau électrique du
système bancaire ou du tissu de petites
et moyennes entreprises
mais à quel point son marché est-il
grand faut-il vraiment croire que les
avancées en IA seront beaucoup plus
souvent exploités par des acteurs
malveillants que pour des fins nobles
comme des applications médicales et pour
sauver des vies non seulement l'ampleur
de ce marché du cyberclim est une énorme
mute news mais ce qu'on mesure sans
doute tout aussi mal c'est sa croissance
spectaculaire estimez un coup de 3000
milliards de dollars en 2015 par Cyber
Security 24 il semble avoir atteint 6000
milliards de dollars en 2021 il pourra
atteindre 10 000 milliards en 2025 à
titre de comparaison d'après mes
recherches que j'avoue être un peu
sommaire et donc auquel je ne suis pas
sûr de faire entièrement confiance le
marché illégal des armes ne
représenterait que 60 milliards de
dollars par an le marché était drogues
illégal lui et estimé à 500 milliards de
dollars par an selon certaines sources
alors que le marché de la contrefaçon
dépasserait 1000 milliards de dollars
tout ça pour dire que les individus
louchent enfin la loi pour s'enrichir
ont en fait tout intérêt à investir
davantage dans le cybercrim que dans ces
autres marchés légaux devenus beaucoup
trop classique et visiblement ils sont
énormément à s'y être mis oui car pour
être clair vu l'échelle des enjeux et
des profits potentiels le cybercules est
très loin d'être une affaire de gamins
isolé sur leur machine dans le garage de
leurs parents il s'agit d'un véritable
business d'un crime organisé avec des
fournisseurs et des clients par exemple
en 2012 et selon Wikipédia la menace
prédominante du web était non pas un
virus mais un kit que les clients
pouvaient acheter pour eux-mêmes
attaquer leur victime de la même manière
vous avez peut-être entendu parler de
Pegasus qui revendu à des états à
défendre de surveillance en fait dès
2015 Ginny rometti alors PDG d'IBM
affirmait que je cite le cybercrim et la
plus grande menace pour toutes ces
professions toutes les industries et
toutes les entreprises du monde en 2017
un expert en cybersécurité sondait son
audience Twitter pour voir à quel point
elle était d'accord avec ce constat la
majorité approuvait le message de
remetty imaginez si les voitures le
réseau électrique les hôpitaux ou le
système bancaire mais aussi tout
simplement les systèmes de réservation
de la SNCF ou encore les bases de
données gouvernementales étaient tout à
coup paralysé par des acteurs
malveillants qui exigeraient des rançons
énormes pour rétablir le fonctionnement
de ces systèmes ou si des milliards de
Deep fake personnalisés demandaient à
chacun de vos concitoyens d'effectuer
des actions obscures sur le web en se
faisant passer pour leurs proches leurs
collègues voir pour leur boss please
any of the messenger
everything
Unito verify
face à ce discours réaliste du paysage
des algorithmes vraiment déployés
aujourd'hui les enthousiastes de l'IA se
précipitent souvent pour minimiser la
responsabilité des IA beaucoup vont
ainsi comparer ces algorithmes à des
couteaux oui les algorithmes peuvent
être utilisés pour tuer mais faut-il les
interdire pour autant lors d'un meurtre
au couteau la faute ne revient-elle pas
à l'humain qui manipule le couteau ce
dont j'ai essayé de vous convaincre ici
c'est que la comparaison entre chaque
GPT et un couteau est en fait très mal à
droite surtout d'un point de vue
conséquentieliste en particulier les
conséquences probables du développement
d'un nouveau couteau surtout dans une
société où il y a déjà pas mal de
couteaux assez comparables c'est
conséquences du nouveau couteau me
semble absolument pas comparable par
rapport aux éditions aux conséquences du
développement et du déploiement
précipité de chaque GPT qui normalisent
et démocratise le développement et
l'utilisation de ces outils qui dans les
mois qui viennent et j'espère vous en
avoir convaincu seront plus probablement
utilisés à des fins de cybercrim qui a
des fins utiles au bien-être et à la
sécurité du plus grand nombre autrement
dit le problème du développement et du
déploiement précipité me semble
contextuelle dont le monde dans lequel
on vit avec des contraintes écologiques
et économiques et surtout avec la
prolifération à contrôlée du cybercrime
et avec l'instabilité géopolitique à
l'échelle mondiale accélérer le
développement d'algorithmes surpuissant
à tout faire et sans préoccupation pour
leur sécurité ça me paraît très
nettement beaucoup plus dangereux que
freiner se développements et investir
massivement en particulier dans leur
régulation d'autant que à part dans le
domaine de l'art les applications
bénéfiques à l'humanité de ce genre de
technologie me semble très limité et
très peu convaincante autrement dit la
balance risque bénéfice du développement
des algorithmes de langage comme chaque
GPT ça me semble très largement penché
en faveur des risques et pas des
bénéfices malheureusement cette balance
risque bénéfice est souvent en très loin
de l'esprit de beaucoup le Cool washing
de l'IA notamment à la reliant trop
souvent à la science-fiction ou à l'art
mais aussi l'insistance à parler de
problèmes très secondaires à mes yeux
comme le rôle de l'humain l'empreinte
carbone de ces technologies qui est non
négligeable mais qui n'est pas non plus
délirant ou le fait que ces technologies
ne pas encore conçu sur le territoire
européen fait de soulever ses
préoccupations très secondaires ça me
semble avoir conduit à un grave manque
de méfiance du grand public mais aussi
des chercheurs des journalistes et des
politiciens envers le développement de
ces technologies dans le contexte actuel
ou le cybercrim domine ces algorithmes
sont extrêmement dangereux il faudrait
urgemment investir beaucoup plus dans
leur régulation leur audit voire leur
interdiction or ça malheureusement ça
nécessite non seulement des lois mais ça
requiert plus encore des investissements
beaucoup plus importants dans des
agences de cybersécurité comme l'Agence
nationale de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information l'annecy mais aussi dans
la recherche publique sur la
cybersécurité ne recherche publique qui
je pense devrait largement prioriser le
recrutement de chercheurs orientés
sécurité par opposition à des chercheurs
qui sont très bons dans l'art
d'optimiser des systèmes d'apprentissage
sans attention alors sécurité après tout
le cybercules n’est pas un problème
individuel si demain des employés de
Google de Tesla d'EDF ou de la Société
Générale se font hacker et si cela
permet aux attaquants d'A et de
paralyser des systèmes d'information
critiques de ces multinationales dont
les produits sont utilisés par tout le
tissu économique et la population alors
les conséquences seraient
catastrophiques pour tous pour tous y
compris moi-même même si j'ai fait très
attention à ma propre cybersécurité le
manque d'attention à cybersécurité des
seins peut menacer toute la sécurité de
toute la société dès lors une réponse
collective et nécessaire et les
développeurs chercheurs journalistes
politiciens et juristes ont un rôle
critique dans cette réponse aujourd'hui
encore très largement déficiente
d'ailleurs un autre très gros danger
avec l'attention démesurée donnée à open
heigh ça me semble être l'inattention
que cela provoque pour les algorithmes
les plus dangereux qui restent à mes
yeux les algorithmes de ciblage
publicitaires et de recommandations de
contenu ces algorithmes sont très
largement déployés et ont déjà provoqué
des cas sociaux aux États-Unis au Brésil
et au Royaume-Uni et des génocides au
milieu de mare en Éthiopie et peut-être
bientôt en Inde ces autres intelligences
artificielles qui sont beaucoup moins
spectaculaire mais tout aussi
sophistiqué que chaque GPT sont aussi
beaucoup plus dangereux pour la société
mais il me semble aussi avoir déjà très
clairement violé beaucoup de lois
malheureusement la justice manque
aujourd'hui de moyens et d'attention
pour prioriser l'application de la Loi à
ses entités par exemple pour appliquer
les régulations sur la publicité ou
publicité ciblées en ligne pour punir la
diffusion massive de contenu illégaux
dont Google et d'autres profitent tant
et vu à quel point ce manque de moyens
de la justice me semble difficile à
combler dans un avenir proche je
trouverai cela judicieux d'imposer des
lois simples à faire appliquer comme
hashtag taxons la pub de la même manière
de manière très concrète alors que des
milliards de fonds philanthropiques ont
été versés à des entreprises comme Open
et high pour concevoir des algorithmes
de langage des alternatives dédiées à
l'éthique à la sécurité et à la
gouvernance collaborative des
algorithmes les plus dangereux du web
comme tournesol manque aujourd'hui
gravement de dons et de visibilité au
niveau de la recherche et des médias
dans le cas de tournesol après notamment
presque trois ans on a juste de quoi
payer un salaire de développeur or même
avec les meilleures idées qui soient
c'est très compliqué avec un seul
employé de concurrencer open air Google
ou Tik Tok d'autant que le développement
d'algorithmes vraiment sécurisé est en
fait souvent plus sophistiquée encore en
tout cas sur le plan mathématique que le
développement de spectaculaire comme
ceci étant dit au niveau de la recherche
en tout cas depuis quelques années les
problématiques d'éthiques de sécurité et
de gouvernance gagne en importance mais
vous pouvez nous aider à accélérer cette
tendance en utilisant notre extension
tournesol pour Chrome Firefox
contribuant à la plateforme pour
identifier plus de vidéos de top qualité
et surtout en promouvant tournesol
autour de vous et des journalistes c'est
en encourageant ce genre d'initiative
que vous pourrez pousser les
technologies à être conçu avec davantage
de considération pour la sécurité et le
bien-être du plus grand nombre